voilà cette part
j'ai désiré c'est par la visite de
l'aumônier musulman monsieur bouana
ses prières
m'apporte le plus grand bien dans cette
difficile épreuve que je traverse
[Musique]
ah oui
il ya beaucoup d'effets même que ça veux
pas faire des habits sion il faut les
apprendre à faire les ablutions il faut
les apprendre à faire la prière à la
police elle irradie
tout bambou coolies bardina doux voilà
comme fils ali moustapha
c'est pas beaucoup parce que
l'information n'a pas été continu et
puis des salaires intéressants
[Musique]
ces récits où j'ai su former les
candidats lorsqu'ils seront fort mais
ils seront remis neyret et il sert aux
rats une couverture sociale ils auront
une retraite et ils auront des droits
sociaux à lacets sur série y aura des
candidats à ça croyez moi tout le monde
se réveillera et tout le monde se
présentera bien sûr vous allez
sélectionné tester et les candidatures
ceux qui seront à tout pour survoler les
formations